we were called to the a39 quantop road  in Bridgewater following a report of a  road-related incident involving a  double-decker bus and a motorcyclist  we can now confirm the double decker bus  was carrying 70 Hinckley Point sea  workers and the bus driver when it  overturned  the incident was initially declared as a  major incident due to the number of  people involved and the resources  required this has since been stood down  Emergency Services have been on the  scene since receiving the first 999 call  and we can confirm there have been no  fatalities at this time  54 patients were triaged at the scene  and it's too soon to confirm if any of  these patients have life-threatening  injuries I would like to take this  opportunity to advise the local  residents to only travel we're  absolutely essential due to the icy road  conditions caused by the cold  temperatures overnight and the excess  water on the road